and why is it target hold like Carrie
they'll target their [__] communists
and may hate black people what happened
with that [__] yo every I tried to go by
Action Bronson zelma target he's on
atlantic they didn't have of course cuz
Action Bronson is black they hate blacks
and they're [__] communists and they
support terrorism so [__] target so [__]
target um uh best buy though you can go
get it the best best buy our low key
communist but they're starting to open
up cuz it I saw like a lot of fans were
standing there in the bat album was
supposed to come out to 28 to April we
got which is in 3 2 outward that oh [__]
the album has been shipped so I'm like
okay I'm telling my fans hey cuz my fans
love buying physical so I'm like hey go
and get the physical at these stores but
it was only like four best body I've
decided to put it out the whole country
so it's a lot of fans who's like hey B
you have this CD and the people that
work at Best Buy if it's not gonna do
releases we don't have it but my
favorite persistent and don't take no
for an answer like yo go to the back and
check so they go in the back and bring
out one copy instead of putting all of
them out with all the artwork and oh
yeah with everything but but I mean on
the two on the twenty-eighth it'll be I
mean hopefully it'll be and hopefully to
be everywhere I probably [__] up ever
being a target because they're [__]
communist and um hopefully bestbuy likes
me still it's [__] up because people
don't even go to I went to bestbuy the
other day in this CD section it
specifies so yeah man they said that
money watch me how they're used to be
like a hip-hop section and now it is
like one section of it's a best buy on
my 14th birthday have found wonderland
by kelis which was only released in the
UK so they even had imports coming there
now used to work at Best Buy we used to
get some like fly like indie [__] just
so much I just used to be lost in the
music section and now it's like small
set missed our records and budget gift
cards and washer and dryer